[Music]
hi guys I'm Metta I am a front-end
engineer and consultant at a company
called Tikal and I want to talk to you
today about functional reactive
programming or FRP before I do that I
just want a show of hands who feels
really comfortable about rxjs oh that's
good you're my people okay we're gonna
go into our X just a little bit for
those of you who are new to it and we're
also gonna talk about functional
reactive programming now if you've ever
gone online and looked for resources on
this chances are you've seen things like
this it's pretty right
it's from the Rx website and it looks a
little bit scary but what's more is it's
very very focused on implementation and
not so much on FRP as a paradigm and I
think a lot of the things we have out
there today are like this so they tell
us how to do things but they don't
necessarily tell us how to think in an
FRP way and for me the paradigm or the
way of thinking are a lot more
interesting so I decided to study them
and practice them by building an app
entirely and only in rxjs and that's
what I want to show you today so this
app is a Productivity timer I have a bit
of a DD and this method of working with
timers really helps me focus so I
decided to build one it's pretty
standard in terms of what it does so you
click start and it'll start counting
down then when it reaches zero it'll
give you a nice alert saying yay you're
done working awesome then if you want to
take a break maybe go get a coffee you
can pause it and then if you're me
eventually you realize your coffee break
took way too long so then you can
restart it and today we're going to be
looking at the start and pause
mechanisms here and how they're built in
FRP now before we look at the code let's
talk about the two main building blocks
of FRP which are streams and pure
functions and Camille mentioned
a bit of this earlier but I want to go
into more detail in rxjs so streams are
a type that emits values over time that
means that a stream is characterized
both by the values it emits and by when
it emits them in rxjs they're called
observables and we can actually see one
in the wild in our code now I'm just
gonna comment out my timer functionality
because I want to show you how we work
with observables so this start stream or
start observable is created using the
rxjs from event function and it's
created from the click on the start
button now what does that mean let's
just have a look inside that by
subscribing to it and logging the result
and we can see what this stream emits or
what does it mean when I'm talking about
a stream so now when I click start you
see it emits this value Mouse event
click it again we see another one and
then another one so this is a stream
that emits values of type Mouse event
and it emits them when the button is
clicked so that's its two
characteristics then the second building
block we have here is pure functions so
these are functions that have explicit
inputs explicit and consistent outputs
so that means they return the same
output for the same input every time and
they have no side-effects
so they don't change anything outside
themselves and the way we most often see
this in FRP is through operators those
are pure functions that take a stream as
an input and return a new stream as an
output and we can see one of these as
well we're gonna go for the quite common
map operator now instead of just
subscribing to my start stream here I
want to pass it through the map operator
I'm doing that using the pipe method
that is a part of our XJS and then what
map does is for each value emitted on
this input stream here it creates a new
value based on the function we pass it
and then it emits that new value in the
output stream so now if we look at this
stream again see what happens when I
click the start you see now it's
submitting this
one so it's being mapped to this value
and it turns out that these two building
blocks are enough to encapsulate all of
our application logic and then the way
we want to think here is we want to
think about how we apply operators to
streams to create the results we want I
want to show you my app now and I just
want to start by talking about inputs
and outputs this is the first thing I
did when I was coding my app is write
the inputs and outputs like this in
vanilla JavaScript and there's two
reasons I want to start with this one is
input output is by definition a
side-effect and so I want to minimize it
and contain it and sort of not touch it
again when I'm working on my app logic
and then the second reason I want to
start with this is that it's going to
give me a really good foundation for
structuring my app because my streams
are always going to go from input to
output
now when I say input here I'm talking
about all and any events that happen in
our app so we've seen clicks and things
like user input but also server
responses these are the places where
streams are initiated and then outputs
are sort of the end result of our stream
and that's the place where we want to do
things like manipulate the DOM and we're
going to be handling them in our
subscribe method and so when we start by
identifying inputs and outputs what
we're really seeing is we're seeing the
places where our streams begin and we're
seeing where we want them to go and from
that we can infer the type of
transformations we want to do to them
let's practice this sort of thinking by
analyzing our timer stream so this is a
stream where the input is the start
click and the output is that timer
display that's counting down and so it
means the first stream here is going to
be a stream that emits Mouse events like
we saw and the last dream is going to
emit these strings of timey-wimey values
and it turns out that this is a really
interesting and good first use case
because the two main characteristics of
the stream are getting transformed here
so I'm going from a stream that emits on
the click to a stream that emits
every second and then from that event
value we saw I want to calculate a new
value which is how much time I have left
on my timer and the way it looks like in
code is like this so I'm going to start
with a from event method like we saw
before and I can create a stream that
emits every second
using this timer function that is a part
of our XJS and what it does is it takes
as a second argument a duration and then
it emits values every duration then the
first argument here just tells it when
to start and I wanted to start
immediately so I'm passing in zero there
so the ferme event I think makes some
sense and the timer probably makes some
sense but you see that they are joined
here with this kind of weirdly named
operator called exhaust map exhaust map
is a higher-order operator and that
means it helps us deal with streams of
streams so up until now we've seen
streams that emit values events integers
stuff like that but streams can also
emit other streams and in fact this
ability is what allows us to create
complex behaviors in FRP however when
we're working with streams of streams we
need higher-order operators to help us
manage the result what does this all
mean well looks let's look at it in code
so now I'm going to be using this map
operator again but instead of mapping
the event to the number one like I just
did I'm going to use that to create my
timer
I'll give it a slightly lower duration
so that it goes a bit faster now when I
click my button you can see what's
getting emitted here on this stream is
unobservable click it again and we can
see the same thing and in fact what
we're seeing here is an observable that
emits observables so a stream of streams
now this observable here is the
observable created by the timer function
and actually if you think about it it
makes sense we said map takes a value
emitted on the input and
it's a new value and amidst that value
on the output so it's emitting this
observable on the output however this is
usually not what we want to achieve we
want to get the values emitted on this
timer and higher order operators help us
do that so now let's see what happens if
I use exhaust map like in my example now
when I click the button click it I get
an error yes I always dreamed this would
happen right because I want to return
the timer here and not the number one
because it's expecting me to return and
observable from that function okay so
now when I click it you see my timer's
being created so this is what I want and
then the specific functionality of
exhaust map is that for the first input
it will create a new output then so long
as that output keeps going it will just
ignore any new values on the input so if
I click it again nothing is happening I
don't know if you can can you hear me
clicking probably not but nothing trust
me that nothing is happening on the
click now if this timer was to somehow
complete then the next click would
create a new one but so long as it keeps
going exhaust map is just ignoring any
new input so this is one type of
higher-order operator there are others
who handle things a little bit
differently for example I could use
switch map here and when I do that what
switch map does is for each input it
creates a new output and then it
switches to that output so in fact what
I'm going to see is on click my first
timer is started then if I click again
you see it's starting a new timer so a
new output click it again and a new
output is created and so on and so forth
so it's just switching to the new output
every time so these are higher-order
operators and they're a very central
concept in FRP now I'm sure some of you
are now sitting in this audience looking
at me and thinking
if you are that's okay
you are normal higher order operators
are notoriously difficult to wrap your
head around and it takes a while for
them to click so if this doesn't make
sense right now that's okay let's just
take at face value that exhaust map here
is creating the type of behavior we want
and let's move on with our timer stream
and see how we create the rest of it so
now I have a stream that emits every
second and it's submitting these
incrementing integers so I can use that
to calculate how many seconds are left
by subtracting that number from the
total number of seconds on my timer
which is 1500 and so this is going to
give me the number of seconds left and
then further on down my stream I can use
the map operator again to format it into
the display value I want but for now I'm
gonna keep it like this because I also
want to tell this stream when to stop
and I'm going to do that with this take
while operator that basically just says
only take the values from this stream
only emit the values from this stream so
long as they are bigger than or equal to
zero this is what's going to stop my
timer when it hits zero and this is it
guys my timer stream it's done and this
is the moment do you know that moment in
building an app that you start to
believe it's going to be okay this is
that moment so I've got my timer stream
I've got a handle on higher order
operators I'm feeling kind of good kind
of happy maybe even confident so you
guys all know what's gonna happen next
right well the next thing I think to
myself is oh now I just got to implement
the pause functionality how hard could
that be well as it turns out the post
functionality has some interesting
problems in terms of FRP let's first
think about what we're trying to achieve
here so I have this timer stream and
it's emitting these values I want to
somehow combine it with the
ha stream so that when pause omits it'll
stop it'll stop a meeting these values
however it turns out that in rxjs
the most accessible methods we have of
stopping observables or stopping streams
have to do with completing them and I
don't want to complete the stream in
this case because once it completes it's
never going to emit any more values and
in my case I want to be able to start it
again when start is clicked and this is
the moment when in fact I know
everything is not going to be ok and I
have to go and take a really long coffee
break and sort of think about my life
and all of the choices that have led to
this and why I thought I this was even a
good idea but after I sort of regroup I
get back to this and I look at it and I
realized something this really isn't
about stopping anything at all it's
about switching between two different
kinds of streams and in fact what we're
seeing here is the power of working with
streams of streams because it allows me
to create these behaviors now because I
know I want to switch between them
that's already pointing me towards the
switch map operator remember we saw that
switch map creates a new output and
switches to it so if I can somehow
combine my start stream and pause stream
to both be the input and then map them
to different outputs so map start to
this timer and map pause to this empty
stream then switch map is gonna let me
switch between them and that's exactly
what I do I'm going to be combining the
start and pause streams so I want to
start by mapping them each to a unique
value so that when they're combined it's
easy for me to tell them apart and so
I'm mapping start to one and pause to
zero and then I'm going to combine them
using the merge operator this is a
really central and helpful operator in
all FRP systems because what it does is
it takes as input multiple streams and
returns as output one
stream that emits all of their values so
what I'm going to see as an output here
is a stream that emits one whenever
start is clicked and zero whenever pause
is clicked and I can use switch map to
both map them to different outputs and
switch between them so this countdown
stream you're seeing here that's the
stream I created before what I call the
timer stream and then this never stream
is a part of rxjs and it creates an
observable that never emits any values
and so switching between them like this
is going to provide me with the start
and pause functionality I'm looking for
so this takes me a big step forward but
it also creates another problem for me
because whenever I start this countdown
stream that rxjs timer is going to start
again and it's going to start again from
zero and because I'm using that value to
calculate how much time is left what I'm
going to see in the end in my display is
a timer that keeps on starting from 25
minutes what I want here is some sort of
mechanism to know where I was in the
countdown stream once pause was clicked
so essentially I need a way to store
staked State is a really interesting
idea to handle in frp because if you
think about it streams only ever have a
value at a specific time they only have
a value and they emit now if I want to
somehow retain that value and use it in
the future I need to figure out a way to
do that now it's true that I could save
it to an external variable and then read
from that variable later on but that
would be a side-effect so I don't want
any side effects in my FRP app instead
what I want is something that is able to
sample a value from the stream hold it
and then emit it at some point in the
future what I want is a subject so
subjects are also part of our XJS and
they are both observables and observers
that means that they can emit values but
they can also subscribe to other
observables and this is what allows them
to help this is what allows them to help
me
a state and I want to first show you
what I'm thinking about doing here so
what I want this is my timer stream and
I want when pause is clicked to sample a
value from my time or my countdown
stream and save it in this subject here
then when start is clicked I want to use
that value again to keep on calculating
how much time is left and what's being
created here is a circular dependency or
a loop where my subject is dependent on
my stream but my stream is also
dependent on my subject so that feels a
little bit weird and wrong
but actually it's okay because they're
not going to depend on each other at the
same time and in fact when we're working
in FRP this is something that we expect
to see when we're handling state let's
see what it looks like in coding so what
you want to do when you're working with
these state loops is you want to set up
a subject and you want to set it up
early so that it's available to all
subsequent streams to subscribe to them
or provide them with values and this is
my subject here and it's going to be
subscribing to this stream now what this
stream does is it emits the last value
from the countdown stream whenever pause
is clicked so if my subject is
subscribed to it my subject is also
going to do the same thing so amid the
last value from the countdown stream
when pause is clicked now because that's
what it does this doesn't solve my
problem yet right because I don't need
this value when pause is clicked I'm
going to need it at some point in the
future however I can turn around and get
it in the future by using the with
latest from operator so this operator
returns the last value emitted on my
subject and in fact what it emits is
both the value from the subject and the
value from the timer so then I can use
those two values to calculate again how
much time I have left now the only thing
I want to make sure here is that my
subject always has a value if I reach
this stream and my subject doesn't
hasn't emitted any value this is going
to error and so I want to in it
utilize the subject with a value and I
can do that using behavior subject so
I'm initializing it here with a value
1500 and this is it this is my pause
functionality so it's going to allow me
to pause and start and pause and start
and also make sure that whenever I start
again I'm at the last place I left off
so I know what you're all thinking now
you're all thinking wow FRP is so simple
are you who is thinking that I have one
you guys I have one it's okay it's not
simple in fact someone even asked me the
other day if arcs Jess isn't just a bit
of over engineering I said no
surprisingly if I hadn't said no
probably wouldn't be here today
I'd be maybe under a blanket somewhere
possibly crying I don't think it's over
engineering I think what it is is it's a
different paradigm and so it's
challenging some very deep-rooted
notions we have about what programming
is and that is hard rethinking these
ingrained notions about programming is
difficult for us and this is I think the
friction that makes it difficult to
think about this code and write this
code essentially what FRP is about is
it's about propagating change
that's what streams do and if you think
about it this is actually a really
relevant mental model for the web
because a web app has no reason to do
anything unless some event some change
has happened and then once an event has
happened
our job as developers is to make sure
whoever needs to know about it knows and
that they react accordingly and what FRP
does is it allows us to write code that
accurately describes this process
without layering abstractions and
patterns on top of that and I think this
ability of code to really describe what
it does is the opposite of over
engineering
and I think this is the reason it is
worthwhile to get into this paradigm and
get over the initial hurdle that comes
with learning it and learning rxjs I
want to give you a link to the repo so
that if you are inspired to think more
about this feel free to go there and
play around with it and I want to thank
you for being such a great crowd thank
you